joined this morning by the secretary of
state for wales simon heart mr hart
thank you for joining us on the program
it's lovely to see you again let's talk
about that to start with should we um
why rwanda
well i i i think the first thing is we
have to do with this problem um we have
a very good relationship with randall
it's a it's a it's an up-and-coming
economy it's got a very good record uh
with migrants in this particular issue
uh and it's a it's an arrangement which
i think suits both countries very well
and provides the best opportunities for
uh economic migrants for uh for those
who have been in the forefront of this
particular
appalling problem for us so so long now
and i think that this arrangement is a
really it has the potential uh to be a
really good step forward and a really
humane step forward but the president of
rwanda has been accused of human rights
abuses on more than one occasion
that is true but that does that doesn't
alter the fact that their reputation uh
as far as migrants are concerned and and
their economic progress is phenomenal so
i don't think we want to write this off
now it is a it's a scheme that we it's a
start of a scheme we want to work with
the refugee council other charities try
and make it work but the but the fact is
at the moment the arrangement pretty
well everybody who observes what we see
on telly with
the problem with the channel and the
lives that have been lost the activities
of the criminal gangs which
everybody accepts is not a situation we
can persist within any shape or form
this has the potential i think to be a
really groundbreaking uh way forward
which provides a humane outcome for uh
the victims in question which is the
most important priority um and also make
sure that we honor what we committed to
do several years ago which you've held
us to on which is to resolve this
problem as far as the uk is concerned so
you know so this is the beginning of a
process we have to work with charitable
the charitable sector to get it to work
okay but i don't think i think it would
be wrong to write it off but it is a
country that oversaw genocide of a
million people in a hundred days well in
our lifetimes in my son's lifetime
absolutely but
if we adopt that attitude then we will
never be able to make pregnancy rwanda
is an improving economy with a good
human rights record now and a good
record as far as migrants are concerned
so it would be a natural fit as far as
it's concerned denmark looking at a very
similar scheme to note so it's not just
us looking at rwanda as a potential
partner in this respect so i don't i
think it would be wrong simply to say
what you know to use the historical
comparison
as a reason as a as a reason to just you
know abandon ship and and just not deal
with the problem we have to do with this
problem so will those that we send to
rwanda be subject to uk or rwandan law
that's part of the announcement later on
i'm not going to prejudge what the home
sec
as we heard on that report home second
or p.m we're going to say later on
there's quite a complex it's quite a
complex memorandum of understanding
we're looking at that i think the
numbers for last year were 28 000 people
uh coming across the channel attempted
to come across the channel vast majority
of those were economic migrants vast
majority of those were men uh
those are the those are the numbers
we're looking at some of the questions
yes of course otherwise we'll be here
all day um are there just men that we're
sending
second are we just sending them yes i
think again i i need to be a little
careful about spelling out the detail
there are some sensitivities around that
but yeah the the vast majority of the of
the issues we're talking about will be
for male economic migrants okay and will
they be adult males
yes okay how do we determine somebody
who doesn't have papers whether they're
an adult or not well that's as i said
that's what the homesec is going to be
spelling out later on today so i i think
you know we we i i think we just need to
be careful it's tempting when they get
to dover will they go straight to
heathrow and straight on on the plane or
will we process them uh again there's
there has to be as ever in in the
conversations you and i have had about
this over the years inevitably there was
a bit of bureaucracy around this to make
sure that the process is above all fair
and a lot of this is about fairness it's
not about sort of unnecessary
bureaucracy it's about fairness okay um
in that will children be sent to rwanda
no male
i keep going back to the same uh comment
so i need to be a little bit careful
about spelling out each and every day
but the principle is no so this is about
male economic migrants uh
in the main uh there is a let's say
different set of issues with women and
children and and refugees and what sign
of seekers what will happen well that's
that's going to be much more akin to
what we do at the moment which is
looking after and safeguarding their
interests uh in the uk so that's that's
that
to a great extent pretty patel will
expand a little bit to a great extent
that's not going to alter massively but
what we're what we are going to say
well at the moment it costs about 1.5
billion will the reward about 120
million pounds is the estimated cost of
this particular uh arrangement but again
that's a that's a figure which will
alter depending on how whether the
scheme works or because part of this is
about deterring the criminal gangs as
seeing the uk as a destination which
they can exploit or exploit the people
that they are not sure how it's
trafficking so
how does it deter the criminal gangs
well if they if they're not the ones
that being sent to rwanda are they no
but the criminal the criminal gangs are
exploiting vulnerable people by
persuading by persuading them to part
with vast sums of money on some vague
promise that they get and get them to
the to the uk where all of their dreams
will be uh fulfilled and that's where
the exploitation is happening
exactly we only have a limited amount of
time you asked me a really
precisely that is precisely what this
whole scheme is designed to deter and
that's precisely precisely why we are
want to work with the charitable sector
with the refugee council with others to
ensure that that does not happen that is
exactly the problem we have at the
moment that is why that is why we are
tackling this problem and i you know for
years you have rightly been holding us
to account about this you've rightly
been telling us that something needs to
be done this is something because this
has taken nine months of careful
negotiation okay with the rwandan
government this is going to have the
opportunity breaking up the criminal
gangs
disincentivizing exploitable people
safeguarding the interests the
safeguarding the interests of of people
who have have risked everything to go on
this journey that is that is what this
proposal is money is as good from a
woman as it is from a man so that's why
male economic migrants yeah but they'll
overload their boats with women then
won't they no why not that's
that's precisely what but because of the
uh uh the
the process as it is how do you know
they won't well you i would expect you
you are suggesting that that will be the
case it is not in anybody's not going to
pull up
people smugglers this is this is
designed to have precisely the opposite
effect it is about breaking up criminal
gangs who so far have been able to
exploit vulnerable people in that
process why we call this processing when
they actually well
why are we calling it processing when to
go to rwanda to be processed when
they're never going to come back to the
uk we're exporting them aren't we
what which other word would you choose
to use
when we're trying to say when we're
trying to safeguard people's interests
we are trying to make sure that actually
the
the the manner in which they have been
previously exploited comes down this is
meant to be about being
being able to distinguish between
economic migrants refugees and asylum
seekers try to make sure that people
end up in a safe place with a reasonable
future that is something i would imagine
we could we could join in some form of
agreement okay where the president's
been accused of human rights abuses
let's move on to partygate last time you
were here you said that the world had
moved on from partygate it doesn't look
as though it has um i don't think i put
it quite like yeah you did that's
exactly what you said well i i i think
i said at the time it probably wasn't
actually the end of the matter this is
an ongoing live play this is an ongoing
live police inquiry with sudrey's report
still
yet to be published so i i think
suggesting that the whole thing is over
is probably misrepresenting uh what i
said at the time but the world has moved
on from partygate well i think i i think
what i was just describing is the
attitude of my own constituents in west
wales which were very clear about this
which they wanted an apology they wanted
contrition they wanted some kind of
guarantee if one can provide that sort
of guarantee that this sort of thing
wouldn't happen again and i said i think
by substantial majority probably three
to one or four to one most people
wanted that outcome rather than
necessarily anybody involved with any of
these incidents to be uh to lose their
job as well and that people were and i
believe this to be the case rightly
focusing on the biggest humanitarian
crisis in 1945 in ukraine and i think i
made the point that i don't think on
balance that it is in the
national interest or international
interest or ukraine interest to have a
noisy and loud leadership contest um
whilst we're trying to to lead the
international response ukraine that
happens to be
my view it seems like shared by majority
let me ask you
poll uh suggesting otherwise 75 say that
the prime minister knowingly lied and 55
among 2019 conservative voters say that
uh he lied and that he should go well i
i you wouldn't be surprised if i'm going
to disagree with that let me just
explain why back in june 2020 steve
swinford steve swinford a colleague of
yours wrote story in the times in which
he described that downing street
gathering where boris johnson had a
birthday cake rishi sonak came into the
room they sang happy birthday the event
for which they have now both been fined
at that time written in the paper in
june 2020 okay not a single person you
the metropolitan police
opposition members of parliament
observers commentators the news desk at
the times not a single person at that
time thought that that was anything
remarkable about that's right not a
single one which makes me oh minister
come on he's been fined for going to the
party he's overseen 50 separate breaches
of the law he's the first prime minister
in 300 years to be found guilty of an
offense but and he said
if i may because you do go on let's just
let me finish my question if i may as a
result you know he's overseen the law
being broken 50 times he has lied to
parliament um do you think he's it do
you think he has
your suggestion that he lied to
parliament deliberately department have
you wanted it
seriously do you seriously think that
downing street would have told steve
swinford well the most experienced
journalists know do you seriously think
they would have told him about an event
about an event in certain
in the belief in the belief
in the belief that that was that they
were bending the rules or they were
attempting to mislead parliament it
subsequently turned down are you saying
he did
parliament
are you saying he didn't mislead
parliament because our understanding is
that he's going to go back to parliament
next week to say i'm sorry if i misled
you but i did it by mistake so
there is i mean i know i know it always
makes everybody frustrated
and say oh there's a difference between
misleading and deliberately misleading
we had all of that with tony blair in
the iraq war if you remember the weapons
of massachusetts he didn't direct the
law well
and the suggestion was at the time the
suggestion was at the time that he
didn't understand that
that he had misled parliament that was
the suggestion and it was all the
argument was all around whether it was
deliberate or whether it was accidental
broke the law but the fact that you
think he is an honorable man but the
fact is
do you seriously think let me ask a
question if i can do you say that's not
how this works do you seriously think
does anybody seriously think that
downing street would have given a story
about an event in the cabinet room
which is now the pm of the chancellor
do you think do you think that they
would would have done that if they
thought that event or any in the
immediate quite possibly that
would have been yes i do you you so do
do you think that they would have
actually done that
and then that qualifies as some kind of
deliberate attempt to flank and why
didn't at the time then if that was the
case and this story's happening
when that story was published not a
single person yeah but they put their
hand up and said that is a breach of
code then it's become apparent that the
prime minister has overseen 50 breaches
of the law being broken in doubt i don't
know where you've got 50 from by because
50
uh notices have already been issued so
50 times somebody has broken uh the law
in a downing street
you know more that you know more about
this than me uh it was a statement from
the metropolitan police
well as i say you know more about this
mate i'm not going to speculate actually
but we can't seriously we can't
speculate about it you tempted me last
week and i probably went too far into
sort of speculation states but we can't
speculate about uh
an inquiry which is incomplete you would
be the first to criticize me if we were
trying to second guess what the outcome
is asking you about 50 times when the
law has been broken that this prime
minister has overseen it and you'd still
think
can i repeat what i said last week which
is it you know nobody's i i literally i
don't want to excuse or justify and i
mean i am sort of
appalled by all of this as anybody else
it's not about trying to say that this
was all fine or didn't happen actually
you know we've all had i mean i'm a
member of the government i have to take
my fair share of claim on this we all
have to hold our hands up yes it was a
misjudgment yes i wish dearly that it
could have been uh could have all been
done differently but the fact is that it
wasn't and my fact is you ask my opinion
my opinion is
people who get a fixed penalty notice
should not automatically just because
they're in public life also expect to be
sacked at the same time that is my view
it's probably on the more liberal end of
the scale but that is my view okay one
wonders what will happen if he gets more
than one i'm sure you'll come back and
talk to us but we are massively active
get me in trouble yeah look forward to
seeing you very soon thank you minister
thanks a lot enjoy easter